fällt ihnen etwas ein ein ausweg wie man
den skizzieren könnte obwohl die virus
lage eben ja total volatil und unsicher
ist ja ich denke schon
also erstmal muss man festhalten wir
wissen zwar nicht so genau wie es mit
dieser neuen mutation ist aber in
großbritannien sinken die zahlen
schneller als bei uns also auch diese
mutation ist beherrschbar
das ist ja schon mal hoffnung 1 wir sind
nicht völlig hilflos ausgeliefert
hoffnung 2 ist wir haben ja auch gelernt
wie man übertragungen verhindern kann
zum beispiel indem man den schnelltest
macht bevor man jemanden trifft wir
müssen weg von dieser strategie jeden
menschlichen kontakt zu unterbinden wir
müssen nur die kontakte unterbinden
zwischen infizierten und anderen und
immer noch ist es so mehr als 99 prozent
der menschen sind ja nicht infiziert zum
aktuellen zeitpunkt deutlich weniger als
1 prozent sind infiziert also müssen wir
ihn zitierte finden dafür müssen wir
testen und heute können sie für fünf
euro einen selbsttest kaufen ich habe
gerade wieder 24.000 stück bestellt wir
machen das so dass im übrigen alle
erzieherinnen alle schuld betreuerinnen
auch die lehrer und die abschlussklassen
die präsenzunterricht haben dürfen dass
die das angebot bekommen
dreimal die woche in den schnelltests zu
machen worauf ich hinaus will ist wenn
wir handel bildung erziehung mit tests
sicher machen dann können wir auch
öffnen ihr sollt nicht mehr diese
schwarz weiß debatte auf oder zu für uns
oder wir sollten welche gene konzeptes
zu sorgen dass wir weder bildung
betreuung handel und wirtschaft in
verantwortlicher weise betreiben können
hersteller jemanden hat den eindruck
herr palmer versucht alles um das heft
des handelns in der hand zu halten um ja
selbst zu zeigen dass die politik
gestalten kann und nicht nur zu sperren
kann warum machen sie es nicht genau wie
er oder ist das quatsch wasser palmas
alle ist eine sehr riskante strategie
ist ich sage noch einmal in richtung
herr ramsauer war die bayerische
staatsregierung unterstützt den
beschluss den die ministerpräsidenten
gemeinsam beschlossen haben uns zwar
nicht weil sie nicht wüssten wie die
lage ist auch die in hamburg haben
natürlich eine ganz schlimme situation
gerade im einzelhandel ich habe mit sehr
vielen menschen unterhalten die das auch
ganz ganz drastisch schildern in welcher
lage sie sind
rechnung jeden tag ein laufen und sie
nicht wissen wann sie wieder öffnen
können das ist ja nicht der punkt
das problem ist das werden wir jetzt uns
darauf verlassen dass es schon gut gehen
wird
das ist dann sehr schief gehen kann aber
es war einmal ich habe manchmal glaube
ich verlässt sich gerade nicht darauf
dass es schon gut gehen wird sondern er
versucht ganz zu gestalten richtig
schnell deswegen ist diese strategie
aufgesetzt auch richtig und deswegen ist
es gut dass wir jetzt hoffentlich bald
auch selbsttests einsetzen können zum
beispiel den schulen und kitas und wir
werden jeden lockerungsschritte
natürlich auch verbinden mit einem
verstärkten der testeinsatz von
schnelltests und dennoch wenn sie sich
die zahlen des aks ansehen
wir sind mit dem sogenannten r faktor
der uns zeigt wie stark derzeit noch die
virusaktivität ist mal eben so knapp
unter 1 wir sind bei 0,9
das heißt wir haben gar nicht viel
spielraum der zeit um uns noch eine
verschlechterte lage sozusagen leisten
zu können
und ich kann mir und mag mir nicht
vorstellen wie die stimmung noch einmal
schlechter wird wenn plötzlich die
inzidenz zahlen wieder nach oben wandern
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren